they've survived oppression poverty and
war but for many the worst part of
escaping
has been arriving in great britain
what is life like in this camp it's so
bad man
it's really bad man last week 100
people 30 have corona virus 130 yes
like positive everybody everybody this
is not a lot of
a lot of people here you have birthdays
covid19
is the latest hardship they face a
recent
outbreak has infected more than a
quarter of the 400 asylum seekers housed
at this former military barracks
behind the curtain a man who has tested
positive
this is what passes for isolation and
social
in a statement the government blamed
residents themselves for failing to take
proper precautions
in response they addressed an open
letter to all british citizens
when we are becoming more and more
mentally vulnerable and physically ill
due to the covet outbreak ministers are
intentionally ignoring us
and trying their best to cover up the
disaster in this army camp
i spoke to the man who wrote the letter
signed by 200 of his fellow residents
he wanted to remain anonymous yeah we
just came here
because we had some reasons because we
wanted to save our lives that doesn't
mean we are
some like criminals or we want to invade
your country and that's why we wanted to
change
the uh the people
mentality of asylum seekers
many have been here at napier barracks
for months denied access to legal
assistance and with no idea how long
their claims for asylum
might take accommodation is derelict
there's little access to medical
or mental health care one nurse for 400
people they've been
suicide attempts and hunger strikes in
protest
at the way they're being treated and
it's alleged that staff from the private
company appointed by the government to
manage
this and other facilities like it have
warned the refugees that if they speak
out in any way
they'll risk jeopardizing their asylum
claims
we've got former principles of
schools aerospace engineers barbers
internationally recognized chefs and
athletes
and to to find yourself somewhere like
this
surrounded by barbed wire fencing when
you think this
this is the country that you were going
to to make your life in and to
contribute to society
but this society is putting you in a
camp like this and leaving you there in
limbo with no answer to your asylum
claim
they came hoping for something better
they can't have imagined this
jonah al-jazeera kent